i'm gonna turn on the lights i always
forget hold up
[Music]
you
and your sister and your job
is
[Music]
um
these boots are made for walking
that's just what i'll do
oh is my shoe untied hold on
i really did not feel like working out
today
really didn't feel like it
but
here i am
do i love running no i want to be skinny
there's four people in here we should
have at least four likes
the pringles no
should have at least four there's six
people in here
four likes come on
give me the four
oh actually i do
the pringles yeah
four legs
[Music]
five we're killing it five likes
you were the one
you traumatized me
99 donation okay 30 second spread
you guys ready for this
let me get it to speed
20.
okay
thank you for the donation
yeah nine likes guys
get to nine
there's six of you
one of you's gonna like it
keep jogging while i recover
okay hold on
actually can i pause this
these
[Music]
i'm gonna pause it for a second
the my shoes come untied so easy
i'm double knotting them this time now
okay go back
nine likes thanks guys
get out of 10 double digits
maybe i'll do
the donation
i should do like a system like
a dollar 30 seconds
get me to do a minute or like 45 seconds
five
i don't know i gotta think of it but
like 20 bucks will get you
something crazy i don't know put your
ideas in the comments
this is just a random idea i had
so
i think i want to make it like a game
that i can play
20 bucks two hours
what the
i can't sprint for two hours
but i could do like a mile at full speed
or something like see how fast i could
do a mile
i'm just throwing around ideas
if you're strong i'm not that strong i'm
going to tell you that
two hours sprint
no sir
i wish but no sir
one mile for ten bucks
good
like full speed
thousand bucks two hours
oh god
i would do a thousand bucks two hours
i don't think anyone would send that
though
i could just be out of your damn mind
i could i couldn't sprint but i'd run as
fast as i could
i got a twitch account no i don't know
how to use twitch
i need someone to like sit down and
teach me how to use that
someone call mr beet
to donate a thousand bucks
good luck sir
[Music]
but i'm just running ideas so
i could do like
five bucks or less
30 seconds sprint
ten dollars
60 seconds spread right
twenty dollars
does this sound fair to you guys you let
me know in the comments
all right two dollars 30 seconds sprint
you guys ready
i'll tell you when it starts
to get up to speed
okay my speed is gonna be
9.5
ready
okay
okay
okay um
thank you for the donation
[Applause]
you just run like the terminator guys
i'm not that fast
but throw your ideas in the chat like
what would be
worth it to use the viewer
you guys are like my personal trainer
[Applause]
50 bucks five hours
you nuts
i think 60 seconds should be the bare
minimum
i don't think so because
i feel like if it's an all-out sprint
like if you're actually sprinting
60 seconds is hard
like that's above average
but you have to actually be sprinting
because i think a sprinting has like
like how fast do people go on in track
when they do the sprints
it's not that long
but
i could do five dollars or less
30 seconds sprint
10 or less
60 second sprint
[Music]
20 or less
for like 10 to
20. minute 30.
because here's the thing i did this on
tick-tock you can't make it too low
and the reason it isn't
because i'm trying to overcharge you
it's because i'm not in that good shape
so if i wanna
if i wanna not die
i can't make you crazy because
you never know
when alive just gets crowded and people
just send money and try to kill you
so
but i want to make it fair you know i'm
not trying to like
rip people off
it's supposed to be like a fun game
so yeah i don't know
i'm manifesting it let me know in the
comments you can put your ideas i'm not
saying i'll take them i might not
but i'll read them and think about it
because this is still a
uh
a fun game
i want it to be that's my goal
sonic theme song
i could do that
it's about drive it's about power
bro you don't understand what happened
to me yesterday i got all these texts
i can't believe when you posted that
my ex-boyfriend right i'm like what
what do you do
he has a video of me
on his page
and it's like
talking about
it's like a video of us and then him in
the gym
i'm like what you can't pose
i don't know it's just
irritating
to be honest
so
like some people just break up and don't
post about it
i don't know
we're giving away
i'm about to have burned 100 calories
i'm 5 calories away
so
could the breakout make me think
differently about interracial
relationships
not really um
i think
it wasn't really about like race
more like class to be honest social
class
because
i just think
when you have like a certain type of
childhood and you haven't gotten to like
therapy and stuff like
it's really tough
um
because you just move so differently i
guess
and like fight
argue different i don't know
so
i just wasn't like
used to like
that kind of stuff
i'm just a pretty easygoing person
and that's my problem is i'm really easy
going
and i think
for like the right guy that'll be a
really good thing because i don't really
care
i'm like pretty easygoing but
give the wrong guy like that type of
power
doesn't always go well
so that's my two cents i guess
[Music]
i really didn't want to do this today
i really didn't want to do it oh my gosh
[Music]
look at that
so
[Music]
get me to 15 likes guys if you can if
you want
please
be cool to make it to 20 on this video
but
i know this isn't my normal like
stuff
so
thirteen
two more two more
wow there's six you in here
what five you left okay that wasn't how
i was expecting it to go
oh my gosh
okay
two more likes i want to get to 15 likes
i feel like counts right
two more likes guys two more i'm at 13.
there's a to you
okay whatever um
i'm at
135 calories burned
i've done
15 likes thanks guys
woohoo
38
one
uh i do 30 second spreads
[Music]
so every donation i do 30 seconds spread
um
i'm gonna do some sort of system where
it's like more the more you donate oh
donation
okay
are you guys ready
i'm gonna do a 30 second sprint
okay
i'll tell you guys when
okay i'm starting
seven seconds
20 seconds
so sprint to you
to you sir
sorry i'm out of shape we all got to
start somewhere man
sir
also
you tell me what speed i should put the
treadmill at
you tell me
also if you guys want to get me to 20
likes on the video
that'd be cool
if you want if you want
thank you jonas
i appreciate it
[Applause]
17 we're so close
three more likes
until i get 20 likes
that was my goal for this
video we're at 8.1
see that's slower than i've been doing
i've been doing 9.5
i do the best i can guys
i don't think
the camera really gives it justice to be
honest
but for real
there's 13 of you in here
i need three to like the video
why don't i do some boxing like heavy
five dollars thank you sir
all right 30 seconds right you guys
ready
i hate boxing
i could probably would help me
okay
i'm gonna do
9.5
that's 10 seconds
20 seconds
30 seconds
oh my god
thank you
i'm actually so close to 20 likes
so close
we just need one more
yay 20 likes thanks guys
[Music]
uh
[Music]
mike tyson said
you have to hate to do
like you love it
we said do what you hate to do like you
love it
i don't know
forever is a long time and i feel like
if you're gonna get into a consistent
workout routine
you have to pick something you kind of
like
now
this is what i like i like games
so to me
donations and stuff this is a game
i like games
um
i like playing sports
and i like lifting
so
i would love to go to a gym where you
just play games like workout gears you
kind of do that in crossfit but like
more like
i don't know
like less
with the weights because
more like cardio games like braces and
[ __ ]
i'm at 212 for calories burned
i wanna burn like
350 today
have i heard of david goggins
yeah no he's really good
[Applause]
okay that man is very athletic he's kind
of crazy
[Music]
it's a good guy to listen to if everyone
in a wrong distance i did i ran a
marathon
this was actually a really cute story
my brother um so i was supposed to run a
marathon around when covet first
happened so march
2020
and it got cancelled
so my brother
i still wanted to run it and i just told
my brother i was going to run it on my
own
and
my brother organized all of his friends
to each like run with me
through the different ways and he ran
probably like 12 or 13 miles with me
without even training he was so nice and
actually that's one of the nicest things
austin ever did
um
yeah
love my brother
i really like my brothers actually
it's kind of what got me into right now
because
all these women would be talking [ __ ]
about men
and i'm like did none of you have nice
brothers
i mean don't get me wrong they both can
be [ __ ]
sometimes
but in general like
i love my brothers
i love my dads i probably get
along with them better than
i get along with like the girls in my
family
so
[Music]
without stopping
well i wish i had to pee dude
i actually added a lot of time because
it wasn't like
there were rest stops or anything
or water cups so i had to like just
hold a water bottle basically in my
pocket
and they would like bring me stuff
and like use gas stations and [ __ ] to go
to the bathroom if i needed to
so
kind of annoying
but
the marathon was canceled so i couldn't
do anything about it
[Music]
um i'm not so fast by any means
oh my god i'm that fast
but
yeah i trained a lot to do that marathon
that was terrible that took up so much
time
it was my time
oh god i don't know like 12 minutes 30
seconds per mile something like that was
my average maybe more maybe 13.
i don't remember to be honest
i probably could look it up and that
might run
it wasn't it wasn't impressive
so
it wasn't anything i was going to post
on social media at all
so
yeah
no it was not impressive i just wanted
to finish
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm almost at 250 calories
i want to burn like 350 today
[Music]
you might come to england you should i
love england
it doesn't need to be impressive
that's my thing i posted
i just remember posting that
i finished the marathon i was like i did
not want to put my time out and give
these haters an energy
um
yeah that was my only goals i wanted to
run a marathon once in my life
and i hated it it was awful i don't
think i would do it again
it was so terrible
like
literally worst day ever
12 minutes per mile for a marathon
it might have been more i don't want to
tell you guys the wrong thing
it might have been more i have no idea
it was
like almost two years ago now
and let me tell you when i finished the
marathon i was done
i was done with it i was
i was so over it
you eat one meal per day
i've tried fasting
it does not work for me i'm i'm too
hungry of a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone start donating
maybe not everyone
i'm gonna do ten sprints
there's eight people on here i could do
eight friends
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
getting hit also we're just
running at a constant speed
what is volleyball when i go back
at home oh my gosh
i've just been like lifting to be honest
and like going on the treadmill until i
burn 300 at 350 calories ish
um
but
when i'm at england
i mostly i'm like doing all cardio
because i'm playing volleyball
and basketball
so
[Music]
i don't know if that answers your
question
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
i wonder if i can get to 25 likes on
this video
i'm at 20 now i was excited by 20. i'm
gonna get to 25 or 30.
that'd be so dope
you don't have to
but
if you wanted to
how long does it take you to get to 250
uh
it runs a fast iran
it's like 120 per mile
like calorie wise usually ish
so like 20-ish minutes
like 20-30 minutes i'd say
[Music]
depends how many sprints i get
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm about to hit 300 calories
300
about 50 calories left
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
have i dealt with any serious injuries
uh
i have a partially torn rotator cuff
um
from years of swinging basically for
volleyball
so but it's a small tear it's like
15 so i don't really do anything about
it i just like
leave it and stop when it gets sore
i'm tough i'm not a [ __ ]
yeah i like dislocated it partially
during a game
i'm tough though i for real
like took a little bit off they sent me
out
i just went back in nope
21 likes thanks guys i want to get to 25
this live stream that's my goal now
so if i go to 25 i'd be excited
be a good day
so
21
four more there's ten of you in here if
four of you could like it
[Music]
it's free it just takes a second quick
like
on the video
[Music]
22.
[Music]
can i explain the breakup
three more likes guys
three more
i bet you came from a tick tock
look
it was toxic it was
there's a lot of stuff going on that
just shouldn't have
and
[Music]
i broke up with him like a month ago
and it's really frustrating that he's
posting about it
because
i just think we're adults
so
[Music]
yeah it just
wasn't we weren't a good fit
so
happens life goes on
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm almost to 25 likes guys three more
three more likes on the video
oh i agree i don't see why people can't
want things let things go
and not well it makes me mad because he
didn't even tell me he was going to post
that video
people just texted me about it i'm like
i'm almost at 25. two more
but people just texted me about it
and it's just like frustrating
because
[Music]
i wouldn't have cared but you literally
put my face in the video
you could do whatever like
i got broken up with them
like what i don't know whatever you want
but
how tiring is playing volleyball i don't
find it tiring because i have so much
fun
like i love playing volleyball
two more likes guys 25 we're so close
on the video
sorry pearl on the bird's head you can
still have your nba babies
what do you mean i gotta find someone
to
do that
guys two more likes
two more
i really want to get 25 i think that
would be cool 25 likes
on the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
okay i did 350 calories i'm gonna go to
the gym
to squat
is the uk better than the us hell no
i'm biased though i'm a big i love the
us
never saw myself living anywhere else
permanently anyways
for a year or two
in my 20s
[Music]
let me grab my air pods
okay guys
i'm gonna go squat
thanks for watching and the donation
it's very nice you guys
but i'll talk to you guys later